Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcasts. And I've
just checking in on you.
All right? I can't even tell you what a
great mood I was in seven minutes ago,
seven minutes ago. Everything was fucking
fine. And then what happens? What happens
in my whole technology fucking
worlds? It just, you know,
Internet's not working.
I got to go into the one room in my house
where the Internet works for whatever
fucking reason. Uh, you
know, it's a cloudy day.
Uh, you gotta upgrade your fucking
something or other, you know,
all I wanted to see,
you know,
I found out that Liverpool lost the cup
final and I know what all you assholes
and of folk do you find out
now you know why? You know,
I just found out now because I
have American Internet. Okay?
Do you know how many pages I have to
scroll through to find fucking soccer
highlights? Immediates it's after
the German scat films. Okay.
That's where the fuck it is in
this country. And by the way,
I found out that most solid guy
got his shoulder yank out by some
content on the other team. And,
and good luck trying to find a
video of the actual goddamn play.
I swear to God,
I want to fucking find every content out
there that is acting like they have the
video.
Do you don't,
one of the websites I went to head
it had the silence of the crowd.
That was the video. I don't
want to fucking see that.
I want to see the injury.
Fuck. I will sit there and look at some
fat cunt crying over his fish and chips.
I want to see what happened.
Cause this,
the picture that I saw looked like that
guy grabbed it. Pulled the Kelly Olynyk.
Yeah,
you fucking grabbed onto the
thing and fucking yanked it out.
MMM.
[inaudible]
anyways, uh, let me look. What kind
of fucking world do you live in?
Okay.
We are trying to get more money off of
advertising by pulling some shit like
that. Swear to fucking gold again. Legal.
We'll have flooded edge babbled.
We'll have them walking out of the
stadium with his fucking arm in a sling.
Hey, yeah, you got, you got,
you got the Zapruder film.
Ah, yeah, we got it. You know,
what do they do? Huh? They
show somebody fucking with the,
their hand over their mouth. They don't
show the actual fucking assassination.
Um, God, I was in such a good
fucking mood since such a great mood.
You know, I woke up, daughter woke
me up. Who's kidding? Who Right.
Made a breakfast as I always do.
We had a great time.
We sang the Etsy petsy spider 5,000 times.
I was in a great mood.
And then for whatever reason, my stupid
recorder, the metronome got turned on.
I did not to turn that off. So, uh,
rather than relaxing and trying to
figure it out, I broke my headphones.
Can you believe it like this?
This all all unraveled. You don't,
my wife loved me seven minutes ago.
I'm turning 50 and I'm still behaving
like this. I just broke one of my toys,
like a goddamn toddler.
Do you guys realize that that's
you're listening to a child?
Maybe that's why God had me go bald
because I was acting like a baby.
He wanted me to look
like one big old baby,
a big old bearded baby. I should
be down in Coney island. Right.
And they should just have me and one of
the cages next to the bearded lady and
just have me trying to fucking figure
out something that involves any remote
basic technology. You know,
look at that big old angry baby.
He's 50 years old,
but you wouldn't know it.
And just watching me break in
fucking headphones and recorders.
Ah God.
And I'd love to tell you that turn 50th
is profound thing and that I'm going to
change, but I swear to God
I'm not, I'm going to be,
I'm going to be breaking my walkers when
I'm fucking 90 and I'm gonna sit 80 and
then I bumped it up to 90
cause I just said walkers,
there's no fucking way, you
know, speaking of which, um,
I'm back to working out again yet another
time attempting with the shoulder.
Cause I,
I'm impatient and I,
I moved to up too quickly in weight
and I re aggravate my shoulder.
I don't hurt it again. I just aggravate
it. But, uh, I really do miss,
I miss working out and lifting
weights and all that shit.
Getting a little pump going, you know.
So I'm doing it with very lightweight,
like put it this way, this is
how light the dumbbells are. Uh,
my dumbbells are,
are like pink baby blue.
I have one pound, it's a girls. I have uh,
three pounds. It's a boy,
right? Are those, no,
I don't wait. No two pound,
two pounds or purple.
I got the purple rain to pounders
the, it's a girl, one pounder.
And then I got the,
it's a boy five pounder
and then I got a six pound
that the color their orange.
Right.
It's like I'm living, I'm working
out with Fisher price weights here.
Um,
anyways,
but I got that TRX band and that things
kind of been saving me a little bit. Um,
it's weird. I can't, like,
I can't bring wait up to the
side out and up to the side.
W like much more than three pounds
is Henri aggravate my shoulder.
But for some reason I can do 50 pushups.
Um,
and I don't know why I just told you
that because now every person who is even
remotely a personal trainer, you know,
they're going to start giving me advice.
You can't bring up dogs working out or uh,
I don't know. Something else. How
to shade your beaver. I don't,
I don't fucking know. You always need
three examples. I'm sorry, I choked.
I ran out of, out of thinks
they're anyways, did you,
have you guys been watching the
Stanley Cup final? Not Finals,
the NBA finals start tonight,
but the standing Stanley Cup final,
the first two games in Las Vegas.
And I got to tell you something I really
wanted to hate on the intro that the
vikings, the Vikings, the,
the nights the Vegas Knights had that
game of Thrones shit that they were doing.
Uh, but I get it. I get it. It's
Vegas. They got to put on a show.
They can't have strippers out
there because there's kids there.
It was a kid friendly Vegas show.
I thought that shit that they were
doing on the ice was amazing. But uh,
it was kind of funny how, I remember
in the NBA when guys would dunk,
Aka black guys would dunk and
then they would do make that,
that motion across the neck.
Like we just slit your throat
and they will like that.
Still violate that a is that a gang side?
They can't deal that any by right.
And then you turn on hockey. It's a,
basically a bunch of white people there
are out there dressed like nights than
not even Miami and going across the neck,
they literally have a fucking
sword right across the neck.
Does all those kids there?
You know what I mean?
Maybe because he's dressed up like a,
a night or something. Maybe, you know,
I have no fucking idea. But anyways,
uh, the games have been outstanding.
Uh, it's really hard to root against
the Vegas Knights with that story,
whatever that GM or that coach said at
the beginning of the year than being an
expansion franchise.
He said to the players,
all of you are here for the same reason.
Whoever you were just playing with
didn't think you were worthy of being
protected.
Something like that.
And that's like the beginning of all
those fucking movies. Well, you know,
they're going to win the championship,
you know,
sneak away from the Nazis like that
Sylvester Stallone movie where they played
soccer. Right. That's what the, how
this whole thing's playing out. But
uh, I've become a capitals fan just
because I've been hanging with Josh,
Adam Meyers all these years,
so I got to root for is capitals
plus they've been waiting since 1974.
Who gives a shit? It's been great. Hockey.
I loved, uh, the shootout in game one.
Um,
as far as 10 goals being scored,
I was blown away by how fast,
uh,
Vegas was and just how relentless
there for check was. But, um,
and I did like that the uh,
capitol stuck up for a Tj,
Yoshi and knocked that one guy
in the nights on his fucking ass,
which he got off easy by the way,
compared to what the fuck you guys
had been doing at to a Tj Oci.
They just decided that we're going to
going to fucking go after this guy. Huh?
Is that what it is? Because he's getting
facewash slash boarded crosscheck.
Then he finally fucking snaps and takes
a dump penalty. What's that guy? Well,
set needs to come out and
beat the fuck out of somebody.
But I loved how the capitols in the
second game played a really physical game
and they slowed them down and um,
and Jesus Christ,
that fucking safe.
That is the save of that might've saved
like if the capital's win the Stanley
Cup, he got us to say right there that,
that, that fucking saved. They go,
they go back to Washington.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say really obvious stuff out there.
They got a big uphill climb to skate.
Although the Cavaliers were down o two
to the Celtics and came back and won four
out of five.
Oh God,
am I see when the red sox lost to
the mets in 86 we won the first two.
You realize that if you win the first two,
the other team has to have to win four
out of the next five and all you gotta do
is go two and three and you're
fucking blow it. Oh, it hurts.
Um, hats off to the Vegas crowd.
I got to give it up. You know,
the NHL chose so many wrong
cities throughout the years,
you know, to try to get excitement
going. You know, Carolina,
Phoenix, Atlanta, I mean, you know, Miami,
it just, you know, and I just was,
I was of that mindset of
what the fuck are they doing?
You know, why don't you just
put one in mobile, Alabama?
Nobody gives a fuck about this shit.
You're going down into basketball
and football, country stock,
car racing and moon moon,
Shannon w you know,
I mean they,
they would rather stand
along the Appalachian trail
and cheer on a hiker than go
to a fucking hockey game south of
the Mason Dixon line. That was my,
my belief. Oh my God, am I
fucking a, I'm quoting Bon Scott.
That's mad
damaged gym.
Um, but I, I stand corrected
because I got to tell you something.
Fucking Nashville in Las Vegas,
the level that the fans are going crazy
in the stands that they'd go in more
nuts than a,
anybody in the original six.
Granted we understand the game more so
we don't have to fucking scream and yell
like that,
but I think the Trifecta is going to be
Seattle as much as I trashed him earlier.
Those are great fans in Seattle.
They don't need any help to be
any louder than they already are.
But I will always contest the volume of
that football stadium cause I went to a
home game there and people just chatting
before the game and I was like this is
really fucking loud. And people
just talking normally. Um,
anyways,
it was like that fucking Metallica album
where they made it like louder than 10.
The one that looked like a coffin in
a pussy on the, on the, on the, uh,
the album cover you had to like halfway
up and it was still blowing your
eardrums out to the owner of
the Seahawks produced that one
better. Um, anyways,
uh, I don't know. I'm
just think that that's,
that's gonna be this
resurgent and resurgence
after some missteps and some
of these cities by the NHL in.
Yeah.
I don't think that it will ever
quite go mainstream though. You know,
I actually watch game one at this cigar
bar. Oh, look who's here. The lovely Nia.
What's that?
Who's that from
when the one of the batteries for
her little, uh, toy gonna come.
Okay.
Yeah,
they like watch batteries.
She has this little creepy little purple
monkey that she absolutely loves and it
just freaks me out. It's like this, it's
something you'd see in a horror movie,
right, with that high pitch voice. Yeah.
It's fucking head spinning around.
Stays on your finger.
Can you, can you close the door, Nia,
so she doesn't hear all my filthy,
filthy talking here. Oh, bring
her in. Bring her rent. Oh,
it's the kid hour
she's coming in.
Oh,
the itsy bitsy spider went up the water
spout of saying this thousand times
today down came the rain
and washed the spider out.
Hi. Can you say hi? Can you say hi?
There you go. Can you
say, can you say Dada?
Say Mama. Yes. Right.
You know where your bread's buttered.
Can you say Mama?
There you go.
Can you say baby,
you go.
Can you say thanks?
Can you say please?
You say dog. What else should she, she got
nice.
Very,
yeah,
that's right.
My favorite thing, I love that. That I
get the mornings of mine, but with her.
Ah, that's right. I wake, I wake
you wake me up a change your diaper.
If we give you your Baba, right. And
then I always make her breakfast.
She eats her breakfast and after
every bite she has to go. Mm.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah. What did you think about what the
capital's didn't game to how they, uh,
oh my God,
that was a real showing tell you they
got out there and they played that game
and I was like, whoa. He say whoa.
Wow. Yeah. She likes it. The
bubbles, those little bubble things.
She likes you blow the bubbles.
She likes to run into them and break
them with their face and go and go,
whoa. Being bubbles, right?
Like bubbles.
Yeah.
Actually getting shy. Um,
all right, so nia, can you,
can you break down for the white audience?
What's going on with Drake and Pusha t?
I actually listened to the song,
I'm like, all right. So you know, he
knocked up a porn star, allegedly,
allegedly,
uh,
this isn't going to end with a gun
battle, is it? No, that is not, no,
that's not who those guys are. Those
days are over by the, Oh, it is. Okay.
No more gangster. You, you shot me in
my live or you shot me. You shot me.
Oh Jeez. Like I, that guy
drives me up the wall. No,
push it.
See had such,
I can't listen to Drake
that took shots at Drake,
Drake shop back,
Pusha t shot back and Pusha t shot back
in a way that was even more devastating
than Drake's. Okay. Do you ever listen
to white music when that happens? Uh,
white music when, what happens?
Uh, answer songs in a whatever,
giving each other crap at whatever.
Do you know what the original one was
as far as I know, the original one?
Uh, well maybe it was the Flinstones
when they had bugged music.
Bug Music. I can't stand
bug music. Yeah. Yeah.
He said, yeah. Yeah. You remember
episode? Yeah, they will.
They would trash in the Beatles
and the Beatles never answered it.
They were above. I'm
kidding. The, uh, the first,
the first one was a Neil young made
a song called southern man. Okay.
And Tom Petty trashing them?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Sweet Home Alabama. Okay.
Is An answer song. Okay.
It's all in the thing.
I hope Neil young will remember.
Southern man don't need him around.
Anyhow. Sweet home, Alabama, you know,
and they, they never, they never
shout at each other or anything. Why?
Why are you being an asshole?
Because you're like wow. Yeah. Wow.
Oh Huh.
You repeatedly,
that's why are you being in a hole?
I don't know what happened.
Neil young and who's saying all
right, I'm done with you. Okay.
Leonard Skinner. Oh, lynching
and skin of what does it,
you're always [inaudible] did you
hear her? She just talked to me.
That's the way she talks
to like waitstaff, people
going out to eat with you.
It's just like,
oh my God.
Hello.
I'm telling you. Oh my gosh. P You, you
get so upset when I say that. Lou you off.
I think, uh, yeah. Jesus.
What just happened but what happened?
I'm glad I'm not on the watch.
Could she just hit this back
up cause this was, yeah.
W
I'm going to tease you out of that.
Bye Bye.
Bye.
See you later.
Yup. All right. She gets so mad
at me when I bring that up. Um,
anyways. Yeah, I actually
listened to the song,
the pusher t songs so I could be
informed about what was going on and uh,
you know, I thought he brought
up a lot of points and a,
I dunno, my answer song be like
a, yeah, I banked a porn star.
We've got a kid and it's
costing me a lot of buddy.
Anyways, I still got enough.
My own Lamborghini. I Dunno
what, what? What do you say?
What do I have no idea? What
am I talking about here? Why?
Why can somebody please send me the
video of this most Salah guy getting a,
this, this cheap shot here. That is what
happened, right? Because I was thinking,
how the hell do you separate
your shoulder playing soccer?
You're not allowed to use your hands.
I would think like the one thing that
never happens is you don't have any
fingers, hands, wrists, any of that type
of stuff. Injuries in soccer, right.
Although with all the diving, I'm sure
you know, if you dove a little too hard,
maybe you could break your wrist. Why
do I trust soccer? I actually really,
I'm really starting to enjoy it. I have
no idea why. You know, why I started off?
I was in a crabby mood. I just tease
my wife about the fact that she, um,
you know,
is less than cordial to waitstaff.
You know what's funny is when she goes
into a restaurant, she becomes me,
which is she has expectations of people
and when they're not met, she like,
you know,
gets a fucking attitude.
I'm not saying she starts throwing plates
or anything like that, but good Lord.
Um, anyways, uh,
let me read some of the advertising
here for this this week.
This is an offer Thursday,
isn't it? Hey. Hi. Hi.
Hi. Do you have any respect for the
fact that I'm doing a podcast right now?
I know cause I have to ask you something.
What are you going to be
leaving after your podcast?
Take an Uber to my appointment that I
have sent to come back and take my car.
Because your car is blocking my,
okay. No, I can move it if
you want right now. Yeah, no,
I don't want to be talking
about this on the podcast.
This is not interesting to people
that our driveway is so small.
I have to move my car so you can move.
Okay. Well, um,
oh, it is for reads. All right. I
got to read the advertising here.
When do you need me to do that now?
Or I could take an Uber and just, you
know, if you're going to later on,
be able to take a car later.
Okay. Do that. Do that then.
All right. I'm almost done
with the pockets. All right.
Four sigmatic Nif Sigmadek,
that was a big Nas album, right?
No,
sorry for Sig Sigmadek.
Four sigmatic mushroom
coffee forcing. Oh my God,
you can be tripping.
Four sigmatic comes from Finland,
the same country that gave us Santa Claus,
angry birds,
Tuukka Rask and mushroom coffee.
Uh, also, uh, what's his face?
Uh, um, from Formula One,
the hell's his name. They're
not Nico Rosberg. The guys
who's driving their note,
uh, felt Terry Botox. Right?
Finnish people consume more coffee
per capita than any other country,
almost three times more than Americans,
you know,
and they don't seem to be out of
their minds when I've been over there.
They seem like really level headed people.
You think they'd be all wired and shit
during World War II when there was a
shortage of coffee,
the finish boiled mushrooms that
grow on trees to make coffee.
Mushroom coffee has half the
caffeine of regular coffee,
but it's twice as magical
al magical,
easy on the gut,
less acidic,
and you don't get the jittery
feeling you get from regular coffee.
I'm already ready to drink this stuff.
I love mushrooms.
The flavor is add your thoughts on
the flavor. Will I haven't drank it,
so I'm going to say it's like hot
mushrooms and definitely not as shrew.
Me As the mushroom you take on spring
break or a Coachella. All right,
so you don't start tripping.
This product is ideal for adult children.
Millennials that work and
hippies that smell good, uh,
called add depth show.
Genic it gives you extra energy
without more caffeine or sugar.
I'm sold perfect for creativity.
Does it help you with technology helps
you when you need to get work done?
I can't believe I broke my headphones.
Think of it as supercharged
instant coffee comes in,
easy to use and carry
single serving packets.
Just add water perfect for travel
and when you're on the go cost,
just a dollar 50 per cup.
Get 15% off your first
purchase with the code bur bur.
Just go to four sigmatic.com/burn
and try yourself. F, O, u, R s I,
g, m, a t I c.com/bar and
try for yourself. Hey,
maybe if you're trying to cut down
on coffee, you can drink this stuff.
Still be creative and not
be bouncing off the walls.
A stitch fix style.
Some of us have it,
some don't,
but it's just because the census,
but just because a sense of style seems
elusive for some doesn't mean it's
impossible to attain. Oh my God,
this feels like every eighties movie.
Is somebody going to get a makeover?
A,
there's no time like the present to
discover the style you never knew you had
and you can with a little help
from our friends at stitch fix.
Stitch fix has reinvented
how we find and buy clothes.
I need to buy some shirts
and maybe I should use this.
Just answer some basic
questions about your sizes.
Favorite styles and budget right from
your laptop, smartphone or tablet.
You're personal stylists
then springs into action.
Hand selecting hand-selecting five
brand new clothing items just for you.
I know,
I know.
Personal styles sounds like something
only the rich and famous can afford a
personal stylist, sorry, but you can
to stitch fix style stick stitch fixes.
Styling fee is only 20 bucks,
which is applied as a credit
toward anything you keep.
And since your personal stylist uses only
your preferences to pick your clothes,
you're still in complete control.
Once your items arrived, try him on,
only pay for what you keep. Uh, don't
like something. Need another side,
just send the items back,
no questions asked.
And shipping is always free on both ways.
Get your fix whenever you want or sign
up to receive. Scheduled shipments.
The choice is yours. I love stitch fix.
Evidently, and I know you will too.
Call to action.
Hurry to stitch fix stitch
fix.com/ [inaudible] to get started now,
keep all five items in your box and
you'll get 25% off your entire purchase.
That stitch fix.com s t I t, c h F, I
x.com/berbee you are our stitch
fix.com/ [inaudible] all right.
Hello everybody.
He likes,
there's nobody on the planet
like you that no body does.
It better makes me feel sad for the rest.
So why would you buy a mattress
built for everyone else? Uh,
working with the world's
leading sleep experts,
helic sleep developed a mattress that
customize to your specific height, weight,
and sleep preferences so you can have
the best sleep of your life at an
unbeatable price. Here's how it
works. Go to helix, sleep.com.
Fill out their two minutes sleep quiz,
and they'll design your custom mattress.
They can even customize each side
for you and your partner, um,
or your wife in 2018 and like sleep is
taken customized sleep to the next level
with helix pillows.
The all new pillows are fully adjustable.
My pill is adjustable. You just punch
it a couple of times or fluff it up.
Are you advocating pillow,
domestic violence?
The all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of sleep positions
or body type. He likes sleep,
has thousands of five star reviews,
plus you can get a 100
nights to try them out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash pro right
now and you'll get $125 towards your
mattress order.
That's he likes sleep.com/burr for
up to $125 off your metrics Heloc,
slate.com/burb oh look what's left.
The only people at
[inaudible] Mian Ds. Where are
the fucking whores? Doo, Doo,
Doo Doo beyond ds beyond ease.
Your pregame was a
fucking bore you live in,
in Vegas with all that crack.
You came out with some nights and the shit
was whack. I'm sorry, I never see work.
It just rubbed me undies. You've, you've
definitely heard me talk about me undies.
You've heard me sing about me undies.
No more sweaty balls and
[inaudible] me undies.
If you have sweaty balls
and you fall on the ice,
you balls will stay,
but you will leave.
Then you have your scrotum on your
fucking sleeve. You know the fun,
comfy undies that feel as good as they
look to those of you who haven't tried
them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get incredible underwear
sent to your door with me on these.
You're going to have to leave the
fucking house for anything anymore.
Meaning no more hunting around for the
perfect pair at a crowded store and
eventually settling for good enough be,
and these are made with sustainably
sourced material from beechwood trees.
Jesus like Budweiser, Beachwood
aged, uh, they're naturally soft.
Makes a fabric that won't sag or write up.
Trust me. Once you get a put a pair on,
you'll get a,
have you seen that patriotic fucking
beer that Budweiser is making?
I mean, how much money can
you make off for like it's,
and then they had like the name of a
veteran on the side of it, you know,
it's like, dude, I was already
going to drink your beer. Okay,
I already support the troops.
You know,
I don't support what the fuck we're
doing over there in the Middle East.
So I can tell you that a w which is far
as I can tell is slowly going bankrupt.
You know, I'm all for getting
these bastards, but can we,
can we get like a fucking more
cost effective way of doing it?
Can't you just drone it up?
Me undies is so sure you'll love your
first pair that if you're not happy,
they do whatever they can to get you
into the right pair. And if they can't,
they can't keep them in the return,
they'll refund you.
So it's really a,
it's a risk free.
Try the best underwear ever
derails what a cheap best.
If you have to be to order this
underwear and be like, I didn't like him.
And if you keep them
and get your money back,
if you're already part of the [inaudible]
family, I'm sorry, the Mandy's Fam.
Yolo, tell your friends about it
through their referral program.
This is like Scientology of underwear.
They'll get a discount and you'll get a
store credit. Wenwen still not sure. Well,
[inaudible] has a deal for my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 20% off
their first pair of me undies and free
shipping.
That's 20% off plus free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your me undies.
We'll be very happy.
Get your butt over to [inaudible] dot com
and treat yourself to get 20% off your
first pair of free shipping and on
a percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's Mandy's dot com slash bar mmm.
Yeah, I feel like the u s government
right now with the money, you know,
considering there's no
end in sight to this war,
there's really no exit
strategy or any of that shit.
And how much money is fucking costing.
They're kind of the ever see like one of
those talk shows where the husband's at
work or something. And he finds out his
wife ran up all this credit card debt,
you know, then of course it's a talk show
so they still side with the woman. Ah,
you need to work longer to
pay off all of her yoga pants.
It's my doctor felt.
Um,
right now I'm copying and
pasting that wine advice, uh,
wine town advice to my wife too,
my wife.
Um, why did I give a shit about being
rude to the wait staff? You know, why?
Cause she always trashes
me and my behavior.
I'm going to use that in the future when
you start treating the people and in
and out burger a little nicer.
Maybe I will work on my attempt,
but you know what's so weird about FTE
FTE a flip out and then you calm down and
then you just looking at your
broken headphones on the floor.
It's just that sadness, you
know, why did I do that?
Where's the other piece of plastic
that used to hold this thing in? Um,
anyways, that's 31 minutes. I
wouldn't say it was inspired,
wasn't inspiring podcasting
today. It was kind of, you know,
I kind of fed off the energy of the
weather, which is a little bit fat.
Um, I'm going to be running my hour
around La, wherever I can get up.
I'll be doing 10 minutes spots, 20
minutes, boy, fuck, I can do it.
Getting ready next week
for Dublin in London,
England. Um, some people have asked me,
why aren't you playing
more cities over there? Uh,
it's because I'm going over there
for my birthday. That's why.
And I'm doing two quick shows and um,
and then I'm going to just,
you know, turn 50, I guess.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing,
but I'm definitely going to
come back and um, I dunno,
maybe a next year or something like that.
I want to go back and do a,
a toy like I did the last time.
Um,
except I don't know, I just,
you know, I got the kid now,
so I don't know how long
I could go over there for.
And there is just something weird leaving
the country with your wife and kid,
you know, maybe I could bring
them along. Maybe I'll do that.
Maybe that's the fucking move. Maybe
I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll do it that way. Um,
you know what, I'm getting off the phone
and I'm talking to my agent right now.
How about look at that. It just that
out right in front of you guys. Uh,
that's how much thought
I put into my career.
I just talked to myself while
talking to you guys and there you go.
Look at my broken headphones.
I'm sorry, headphones.
Now I'm going to have to throw
you out because you know,
they don't make that plastic piece there.
It's going to end up in the
fucking ocean floating around.
They didn't even have to be out there.
I kept these things so long that they
like, like the shit was flaking off,
you know, that goes up and over your
head and people would always be like,
you got something on
your head. It's like, oh,
just the spongy shit from my old
headphones. I'm sorry, old headphones.
You know, this is like when
somebody kills their wife,
like fucking 50 years into the marriage,
you know,
the fit of rage.
I feel really bad right now.
Are you comparing women to
inanimate objects? Uh, yes, I am.
All right, that's the podcast.
I have a great weekend.
You [inaudible] can somebody please
send me the video d if you've got a flip
phone video of most solid and
his fucking shoulder yanked out.
I just want to see if it's his filthiest
the pictures look all right. That's it.
Have a wonderful
day.
[inaudible] back
is
turned from
[inaudible] said that it
was from Gazans masters,
so
[inaudible]
mmm,
here's something that I, uh, I actually
read a quote from one of these magazines.
I guess evidently a Clint
Eastwood was hyping that movie.
Gran Gran Torino. I don't know
if you guys have seen that movie.
I'm sure you've seen the ads for it.
Where he basically is,
I get up late a lot and you
fucking person of another race
and I'm a white man and I represented
my car represents back when America was
good and the early seventies.
Um,
I guess when he was, uh, doing the
interview for that movie, uh, he calls,
I guess the current generation,
the pussy generation.
And at first it made me laugh
and I'm thinking like, yeah,
Clint Eastwood obviously has earned
the right to call people pussies.
And I'm thinking, wait a
minute, [inaudible] is an actor.
Okay, who plays tough guys who
never loses a fight really?
And even if he does lose a fight
in a movie, it's a fake fight.
So at the risk of making
second sack religious comment,
first trash in the Great Mickey Mantle,
uh,
now I'm going to go out to Clint Eastwood.
Unlike where his Clint Eastwood,
I want, this is my question
for you guys this week.
Where's Clint Eastwood got off like
where's he earned the right that he's this
tough guy.
Cause like he plays a tough guy.
I've known understand that
with like actors. Like I
remember like after nine, 11,
like,
um,
for some reason they wheeled out Tom Hanks
and like that was supposed to make me
feel relaxed as an American.
And I remember during that time I was
doing a joke on stage going and talking
about Tom Hanks saying he's done so many
army movies. He thinks he's a veteran.
You know what I mean?
It's not like you did army movies,
but he played an astronaut.
He was in saving private Ryan.
You know what I mean? And like all
of a sudden, like, he becomes like a,
all these guys, like I said,
you know, here's, here's one
for you. I've got fucking,
you know,
friends out here.
Some were doing the touristy shit out
here in La and I take them down to Mann's
Chinese theater or grooming's,
whatever the fuck they calling it now.
And they got those, uh, they
got the hand prints in the feet,
prints in the, uh, footprints
there in the, uh, the cement.
And I found John Wayne.
I swear to God,
John Wayne had the smallest
fucking feet I've ever seen him.
I couldn't believe it. This is the
Duke John Wayne. This is the guy.
Everyone was one.
Just thought if even breathed on you,
he fucking knocky into next week.
This guy had like,
I think he went to fucking lady gap to
buy his cowboy boots. He's six fucking
the smallest fucking things.
He could've fit both his
boots and his cowboy hat.
That's how small is fucking Fida.
If you ever go to La and you
go to Mann's Chinese theater,
it's on the right hand side.
He had tiny little ass feet,
you know, actors are fucking annoying,
you know what I mean? Sit there.
And they put on fucking leather jackets
and they play these bad asses and it's
just like, dude, you're fucking, you're
an actor. If you had any real fights,
Clint, Huh? Somebody of
a fucking rear engine,
the drive through at Burger King and he
got out and you settled the score maybe.
Yes. I don't know what,
but you know, I dunno.
I don't fucking let it just fucking
annoyed me. And moving on from that,
somebody actually sent me an email
that kind of ties into this, right?
I'm not saying Clin isn't a tough guy.
The guy's fucking ridiculous.
He's 80 years old. He's still
lifting weights, you know,
the way his eyes are squinted.
He definitely seems like
a bad ass. But you know,
I want to see his fight card. I want
to see his arrest record. You know,
maybe he was a juvenile delinquent
before he came up. I Dunno.
I haven't Wikipedia'd him yet.
So,
and
change with
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built burger and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 31st,
2010.
How the hell are you happy Memorial Day.
Let's start. Let's, let's start with that.
Let's show a little bit of respect.
Okay. What are you doing right now?
Why don't you get off the
fucking Treadmill, Huh?
Stand at attention and give
a salute to the troops.
Seriously do. Quick shout
out. Big shout out half.
What am I a hip hop Gj over here.
Big Guy,
big hello from America to
everybody over there. And uh, Iraq,
Afghanistan. Where else do we
have troops? Germany, right.
Still got people over there just
in case they start acting up again.
You know them. That's what you get.
Germany starting a couple of world wars,
you know, I'm glad you did
it. I'm glad you did it.
It gave us a nice rain at the top
after you lost for the second time.
And then us in Russia.
We carved it up and stared at each other
for fucking 40 years going, oh yeah,
yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. And
then we just like, all right,
fuck it. Yeah. And Russia just to
forget it. I think my mom's calling me,
I got to go, but you know, fuck you.
Anyway. All right. And then they walk
away and then we're standing there like,
Holy Shit.
You mean this is all ours
may technically it's not ours, but
there's nobody stopping us. Right.
It's like Bo Jackson when he comes around
and all of a sudden he just sees 80
yards a fucking green. You know
Kenny Easley ain't gonna catch you,
even though he's got the fucking
right angle. It ain't happening.
That's what our corporations did.
They were like,
we're going to put a fucking best
buy and every God damn corner,
this fucking planet.
And we're starting in Iraq because as
far as I can tell on my map that looks
about the middle. Everybody go with that,
Huh? Show her hands. All right then.
Oh, right. Dead. Let's
fucking rally the troops.
This is the best one out of all the socks.
No disrespect to the
air force army and Navy
Udo shores of Tripoli.
I'm a stupid fucking ah man.
Red Cans.
So I don't know where triple Lee is.
What the fuck is Tripoli?
That's it.
A fucking awesome name.
They really picked the right fucking city
town or country when they said triple.
I know it's not a country. Go
Fuck Yourself. A European snobs.
Listen to this shit who think
you're better, right? Cause you had,
you know more about geography
and your jeans are tighter.
You think you're impressing me?
You're not all right.
A bunch of fuck ups.
Really. Amy Winehouse,
that fucking Pete Doherty Douche
bag who's never done anything.
His big claim to fame is he looks like
paste stumbling down the fucking street
and you guys can't get enough of them
and you have the fucking balls to look at
us like we're a bunch of fat fucks.
All right.
Stand Down Europe.
This is our day.
Ah Shit. So anyways, I was actually
supposed to go over to Japan, right?
Little fuck he sucky. No, I wouldn't
do that. I would not do that. Um,
I was going to go over there to go
entertain the troops and I don't know what
the fuck's going on with that Gig. It's
supposed to be a nice three base. Bing,
Bang, boom. Brian. I was gonna
come land in, in a chopper.
I was going to do it up just like an
apocalypse now have a couple of chicks
coming out. These boots are made for
walking right tassels on their titties.
America throw some place
stations out into the crowd,
play a drum solo with some fucking
chop sticks, you know, little America.
That's what I was going to do.
And I don't know what happened.
All of a sudden now it's like I'm playing
a rec room on a fucking Navy reserve
base in Rhode Island.
I don't know what happened to the tour,
but I was supposed to be going over there
and I was going to go over there and I
was going to give it my all and I was
going to hang for next to, you know,
four or five days eating Sushi,
hanging out in Tokyo. You know,
just looking at a city like what if all
of New York looked like times square.
I want to see it go to what? Go
to a Japanese garden. You not,
you probably don't call it
a Japanese garden. When you
go over to Japan, you know,
kind of like when you go to Philadelphia,
you don't go,
can I get a Philly cheese steak? It's
like, dude, you're in Philly. Just say,
can I get a cheese steak? All right,
everything is officially here.
See that yogurt? That's Philly
yogurt. How come it says, Yo play?
I don't give a fuck what it says.
All right,
you're in Philly. So all
this food is ours. Um, yeah.
So I guess you say, I want,
I want to go see a garden.
So I go see a garden and
then be like Eisai Dai, Dai,
Dai. I don't speak English.
And then I'd be an asshole American.
Like he don't speak English.
Learn the fucking language.
You know?
How fucking,
how bad would that be if you just
walk down the streets of Tokyo?
Just sort of yelling out to nobody in
general and just sort of over everybody's
English.
All right.
I think I've been ignorant
enough on this podcast.
I right now you're probably wondering,
you're probably wondering going bill
last week according to the MM podcast.com
the one and only official fan page
of the Monday morning podcasts.
For those of you who like to follow
along at home with every reference that I
make when I bring up youtube videos,
you want to at your fingertips
when I mentioned old actors,
when I Talk About Yo play yogurt
and you want to look at the carton.
Oh yeah, that is what it
looks like. It's all up on the
mmp.mm. podcast.com. All right,
actually made a little video there.
Uh, let's see. Like Archie bunker. Hey
made a little bit, a little video there.
Edith eating bad. I made
a video for the uh, um,
it's a long story. You'll see I've
got, we have an exclusive video.
It's not even up on youtube
or maybe it is. I don't know.
I don't handle that shit.
I just see the red light and I just
start talking to people cause I'm a
professional just like all those band
members on fucking Lawrence Welk. Okay.
The light comes on.
I start doing whatever it is that
I do to pay the fucking rent.
I didn't know what I'm talking about,
but anyways,
I told you guys that I was going
to be interviewing the, uh,
the wonderfully talented
Nicholas Swartzman.
Is it Schwartzen or Swardson or Swartzman?
I think it's Swartzman with the Real
Nicholas Swartz. And please stand up.
Um, Minnesota's own nick
Swardson grandma's boy.
Don't mess with the Zohan Blades of glory.
All those fucking,
all those movies that fucking every
college kid and immature 41 year old,
soon to be 42 year old like
myself. Absolutely fucking
loves. I love those movies.
Okay. First of all, I didn't
even know, I didn't even,
somehow grandma's boy went under my radar.
I Dunno what I was doing,
but I miss when that movie came out and
I started watching some clips on it.
It's fucking, it's funny as hell. And I'm
going to rent it this week. So anyways,
I was supposed to, um, and
that's what I was doing.
I was ready for an inside the
actor's studio. You know, I was,
I was looking at his body of work and
all that Shit, getting ready, you know,
I wanted to have a good
interview. And then, uh, you know,
when you have everything all
planned out and then just, you know,
this is what happened. Okay.
I called Nicholas and uh,
and I said, you know, are we good for
today? He goes, yeah, no problem. Uh,
gimme and whatever. We were supposed
to meet in like an hour or something.
So I'm sitting there and my fucking,
you know,
my boxers play in my guitar,
right? Doing what I do.
I'm trying to learn these fucking
surfing, all that Surf Guitar, you know,
for those of you trying to learn guitar,
you know, try to learn to play by ear,
so then you're not like,
you know,
borderline retarded in an
instrumental kind of way,
instrumental in an instrument kind of way.
So, uh, you know, there's simple songs,
Barron Aaron, Aaron, Aaron, Aaron on down
there now, now, now, now, now
salt, one fucking string. You
can figure it out. You know,
you'll learn some courts.
I'm fucking doing that shit
and I'm a girl goes up.
Okay.
How I get to take the dog out.
So she walks down the street and just
like in life when tragedy strikes,
you have no idea it's
coming. All right. Yeah.
I'm sitting there trying to learn how to
play. Waiting on a friend went, Eh, Eh,
eh, boo Doo Doo Doo, Doo doot
boop beauty you, you know,
and knowing my neighbors, having the
window open, not giving a fuck, right.
Trying to slowly kill the old man who
lives down below me on a holiday weekend.
I might add fucking three minutes goes by.
My girl is taking the dog around
the block. What could happen, right?
All of a sudden she comes in
opposite dawn. She looks, look at me and
she's like, I just got bit by a dog food,
cheese
freaking out. And I was like, I
couldn't even fucking, I couldn't,
I couldn't process it.
I was like,
you just walked outside to go
take the dog for walking out.
You're bleeding on your leg. What?
What's, what's going on? She had a little,
was a nip.
Fortunately she didn't need stitches,
but now my whole day is in shambles.
It's like,
what the f what did you get bit by?
Was it a coyote? Was Was it? What was,
it was a dog. It was a dog. Okay.
Who's dog was it? I don't know.
They weren't around. It was some lady
there. She helped me out all his shit.
The next thing you know,
I go from sitting in my underwear trying
to learn some bill Haley and the comets.
Next seen on walking up the street.
I fucking don't even have socks on him
walking up on my stupid old sneakers with
my feet squishing in my old new balance.
Right. Why am, why are you staring at me?
Nia and I talking about,
I'm telling you the story as to why
Nick Schwartzen isn't on this podcast.
Come over here. Huh? What did I do?
What? Come here. What did I say? What?
Why did you go? Oh, I got bit by a dog.
Like I'm some sort of jerk or
Dork or something. No, I wasn't.
I was trying to act like you crying.
Hey, let's go. Whoo dog.
That's,
I'm making fun of me.
I'm not making fun of you fucking
told Nick a goddamn movie star.
I couldn't do the podcast.
I have to take my girl to get her
to get up a little booster shot.
Well, I mean, what the fuck is wrong? You
don't realize I'm recording right now.
I'm sorry. Yes, yes. Easy. Why don't you
go over on your laptop and go on Youtube?
He's clearly in more movies than I've ever
been in, so I should probably shut up.
Right?
This is ladies and gentlemen.
If you ever wanted to look up back
pedaling and the dictionary. Oh,
that's my tetanus arm. Oh, sorry. Sorry,
I'm just explaining this. All right. I
thought you were mocking me. I wasn't.
I was mocking the situation where you
just sit there and like nothing's going on
and you know, you walked out to to fucking
take the dog out. What could happen?
Remember I was sitting in my underwears
oh, he's on my leg. Ripped out.
Well,
yeah,
not that chomped on chomped on what you
did was you broke up a rape in progress.
Yes,
that's right.
That's right. This dog
was trying to, you know,
take advantage of my
dog's necessarily rape.
She tried to rape her and she
wasn't having it. And you know,
dogs can't hold pepper spray because
they don't have index fingers. Thumbs.
That's right. And so they bare teeth
and they go at it and a fight ensued.
I was proud of her.
She's not one of those dogs that just lets
other dogs come up and have their way.
She's a fucking slut.
She's not a slut.
She's a dominant female and she's not
taking it. Right. Well that's what I was,
that was the story I was telling.
Okay,
well will you draw a parallel to what
happened to me earlier in the day at the
farmer's market when you get to,
I know it's not about me.
Oh, and the creepy homeless guy hit on
you. Yeah. You hadn't yet an awful day.
I told him, you know, I, you know, this
guy came up to me, I was at the front,
I'm sorry, I'm gee, you're really just
taking this over. And he came up to,
it was like, Yo, yeah I was, I was,
I was buying bread from the
farmer's market and this
guy comes up to me and he's
right in my ear, like all breathing on
my neck really close. And he's like, Yo,
can I get some bread or a
water or something like,
like it was,
it was so awful.
What is that? Some new
street slang for pussy. Yo,
let me get someone at bread,
sugar,
1972 slang solid.
It was terrible. And so I'm like, what?
And he kind of mumbled
something and I'm like, alright,
you need to step off and whatever. Then
he's trades getting close to me again.
And I said,
if you don't get out of my face,
I'm going to punch you in the
fucking face. I was so pissed.
You say face twice,
cause that really kills your momentum.
If you don't get out of my face,
I'm going to punch you in your face
because you're in my face with your face.
And I'm not having that with your face.
No, I think I said, if you
don't get away from me,
I'm gonna Punch you in your fucking face.
That's what I said.
If you don't get away from me,
I'm gonna Punch you in your fucking face.
And he was a Ho Ho you're not that pretty.
You are not that pretty in any way.
Hang on, hang on one second.
You just sounded like you
don't get out away from me.
I'm gonna Punch you in the fucking face.
Do you remember the
cop and reservoir dogs?
One of the most underrated performances
ever in the bathroom with Tim Roth is in
there. I said, buddy,
I am going to shoot you in the fights.
You don't put your fucking
hands in that dashboard,
that classic cop speak buddy.
That's what you just sounded like. All
right, so, so you almost got raped.
The dog almost got raped.
Go Nice.
Both bared our teeth and fought off.
You know these fucking advances.
You know what I'm saying?
All right. I'll write, go
write the script. It's going
to be a nice lifetime movie.
Okay. You taking over the podcast,
they want to hear about me.
Yeah,
that's what happened to Johnny Carson.
All of a sudden you let a couple
people, guest host, next thing you know,
you're playing golf.
Wondering what happened. Yeah.
Beat it. All right. So
anyway, so that was the story.
Somebody tried to, uh, adult let
some person left the gate open, uh,
up to street. And, uh, this
dog came out with another dog.
One was the lookout and the
other one fucking, you know,
came running up, you know,
probably there's a little pink
dog. He, Dick and, you know,
tried to mount my dog. You
know, I gotta tell you,
I got to respect the dog up the street
for its belief in itself that it could
rape a pit bull.
You know,
you know, when they make those movies
about the fucking, you know, the, uh, the,
the white guy from the suburbs who
wrongly convicted, you know, and he,
and he goes, uh, he goes to prison. You
know, I just realized in those movies,
when it's the black guy
who wrongly goes to prison,
who's wrongly convicted
and goes to prison,
there's never any issues about him getting
raped. You know it, he's a black guy.
He'll fucking, you know, kick the shit
out of everybody in there, you know,
and then dunk on the fucking warden
when they have the annual fucking warden
prison fucking whatever game. Right?
But the white guy goes to jail.
It's always worried about
getting raped. So anyways, if,
because they've made that movie so many
goddamn times and you couldn't make it
any better than Shawshank redemption.
But Tom Selleck made that movie.
Somebody else made them.
I came up with who the fuck else made
it and Tom Selleck went to jail and he
fucking,
you know,
he ended up running shit and he respected
his intelligence and all in all this
fucking stupid white guys
shit that they do. Right?
So I'm saying if you want
to write that movie, okay,
if you want to bring that genre back,
if you're sick of seeing to a boyfriend
and a girlfriend who are actually
secretly hit men are spies.
Okay?
If you're not tired of that genre yet.
When the fuck did that start, by the way,
was it Mr and Mrs. Smith and
they've made like 52 of them.
Ashton Kutcher has one coming out with
some other broad and they're standing
back to back with guns in the, in the
titles written in like pink lipstick.
Okay, I'm digressing here.
But anyways, this is how you,
this is how you take that
one to the next level.
This is a tip for all you
Hollywood screenwriters out there.
This is how you fucking do it. You, uh,
you have the white guy not only be
able to handle himself in the prison,
but he rapes the toughest guy
in the prison. Basically the pit bull
version of, of, of a fucking human being,
whatever, the big, the big
fucking just jacked, you know.
Do you ever see a dude just so big?
It's like you look at the, you know,
had an aluminum baseball bat
anywhere on his body that I hit.
He wouldn't even feel it,
you know, even as head.
It would be like three times he'd be like
banging them on the head as he slowly
turned around doing that. That
cheesy Bruce Bruce Willis. Look,
you know Bruce Willis has one.
Look when something's going to happen,
he makes his eyes a little wide.
He makes his eyebrows tents. One of
them goes up a little high and then he,
he makes his mouth like a little
round. Oh. And he turns around.
That's what he does. That's what
he did all through pulp fiction.
He did it and die hard. And uh,
why am I shitting on Bruce Willis?
I like his movies.
What am I trying to tell?
I'm trying to explain why a Nick
Swardson's not on the podcast right now.
So yeah, I was playing guitar. Try
and learn some fucking, you know,
whatever the fire, you know, the names
of the bands. I'm so new to the shit.
Next thing I'm going up
the fucking street and uh,
with Nia who still bleeding.
Okay. I did try to, you know,
clean it up a little bit, but we
also have to figure out, you know,
if she's slowly getting rabies.
So long story short,
we get in the vicinity now we have to
start knocking on fucking doors to try to
figure out,
uh,
whose dog it was and I'm opening
the gates and the gates of creaking,
easy to walk into these
people's house we live on,
like one of those streets are everybody's
house looks like the monsters,
you know, so we, you know,
to a much lesser degree rather than the
gates being like, you know, 10 feet high,
they're like sort of waist, chest height
depending on your height, you know.
So I'm walking in there worrying that
this rapist dog is going to attack me,
so I have this fucking stick
that has a ball on the end of it.
I look like a fucking wizard that
doesn't know how to walk with the cane.
You know,
I got it upside down.
I basically look like some blue collar
guy who was wronged and he's about to
take the law in his own hands, but I'm
not going to get fucking bit right.
I got a weapon Memorial Day,
weekend, hand to hand combat.
I grabbed the shovel out of my pack,
so I'm walking up,
I ring the doorbell and I hear Wu on
the other side. I'm like fucking great.
Right. And then this, you know, and then
I'm waiting for the sound of the feet.
Boom, boom, boom. Come walking up on the
hardwood floors. This lady upstairs door.
Hi, I'm Mike. Yeah, your uh, your
girl. Your dog just attacked my,
my girlfriend and then she
does just, you know, ah,
oh my God.
I'm thorough
thigh that fucking la shit.
We get lazy by the end of the sentence
and you can't even finish the word.
Oh my God. That's my favorite.
You're what? My favorite.
Your your favorite? Favorite.
Favorite? Yeah. Rit.
Not Raw as my favorite anyways,
so she wasn't really like that. You
know what she was, it's the way fucking,
I don't know,
I can't speak for other countries,
but the way this country is right now
where everybody is just so fucking sue
happy,
she can't even express concern or
like a sorrow or apology apologetic,
whatever that fucking word is in
whatever tents and supposed to use that.
She can't express it because
she's worried about a
fucking, you know, yeah.
Incriminating yourself.
Like we're just going to sue
the shit out of her because of,
cause my girlfriends got bit,
you know,
and all I'm trying to do is
find out if it has rabies.
And my girlfriend told me that the dog
was either black and white or brown and
black turned out was brown
and black that she said,
and I couldn't remember
what the fuck she said.
And I knew that she had two dogs
and now I can't say to her the
black and white one. And then
she'd be like, I don't have one.
You have the wrong dog.
[inaudible] you just fucking
a unintimidated me and
that she slams the fucking
door. So anyway, so I had to figure
it out. They had fucking rabies.
Long story short then you know, and then
I got to call Nick and say, ah, you know,
remember how we were going
to do that three seconds ago.
Well since then my dog almost got raped
and my girlfriend got a chunk of her leg
taken out so she's got to go
get a tetanus shot. Whatever.
Long story short was, I cleaned up the
fucking cut, you know, little peroxide,
little bass Treyson I'd
fucking covered the shit up.
And then it went back up the street
cause I realized I didn't even get their
names and their phone numbers and crap.
And I know that the doctors
are going to be like,
well did you get proof that
it doesn't have rabies?
So I had to do that and the
next time I went up the street,
the husband was there and he was actually
cool as hell. He said, sorry about that.
Uh,
don't worry about it.
You know,
I'll pay for the trip to the hospital and
that's all I wanted to hear. You know,
not trying to get in a second Prius
out of a Goddamn nip on, on the inside,
you know of a kneecap. I'm not
trying to do that but I understand.
I understand why the fuck they did it.
But that's basically the reason why um,
the reason why that uh, Nicholas isn't
on it. And this week I'm going to try,
I'm going to actually try to hook up and
do a very special version. You might,
you might get lucky.
It's either going to be next Monday or
maybe sometime this week you might get
lucky. Am I doing next to one? Uh,
and if I am going to do an extra one, just
keep checking in with the uh, the Mlm,
podcast.com the second I've,
I figured out that we are
going to do what I will let,
I will let you know the powers that
be know over on that page and uh,
they will put it up and you'll
have the inside fucking scoops.
So maybe you'll get something on
a Thursday or a Friday this week.
Huh?
How much you guys love in life?
It's a short work week.
Well you gotta do is Olympia way
through fucking Tuesday through Friday.
You might get an extra podcast
with sliding into June here.
Good Times, good fucking ties. But
I was really looking forward to, uh,
I was actually watching a ton.
If you get,
if you guys for some reason
are familiar with nick, uh,
Swarts and you really should just youtube
some of his stuff and then go out by
all this comedy DVDs because like I said,
I'm not putting anybody on this podcast
that I don't think is a, you know,
is fucking hilarious.
And I was seriously watching his stuff
just fucking die laughing by myself.
Even like the quick little videos that
he makes, he's just, he's hilarious.
And I'm renting a, that's your homework
assignment this week. Rent Grandma's boy.
So you're up to speed and a or any
of the other ones that he's in,
but grandma's boy, it seems
like he has the most lines
in it. And uh, I don't know.
He's got a bunch of movies coming out.
God dammit.
I had a fucking movie star coming on
despite what my girlfriend, thanks.
And I was just me sitting here
under my goddamn ceiling fan again.
So anyways. Yeah. So what
do you guys disappointed?
It's just me again. I understand
that. Think I'm fucking thrilled.
Thought I'd get a God damn
week off somebody else talk.
Somebody else talk for a while,
do some shit jokes. Um, anyways,
anyway. Oh, I got an email this week. Um,
remember the old Douche bag of the week
award number that I haven't given one of
those out in awhile.
Um,
I got this really bizarre email from
somebody the other day. He said, uh,
it said,
hey man,
I sent you an email about a year ago
and it was something to the effect of,
fuck you, you really turned
into a pussy, et cetera.
I think though that I was wrong for
saying that I will continue listening to
your podcast and look and looking forward
to any new shit you come out with.
Um, I wasn't thrilled with your
California dog loving bullshit. I mean,
we all love dogs, but we really
don't, don't all talk about it.
You know,
this is like one of these guys.
This is what fucking annoying
me about those emails. You know,
those people where they realize they're
wrong and then they apologize to you and
it starts off as,
as an apology and then you quickly
realize that it's really just an excuse to
start reiterating the shit that fucking
pissed you off to begin with. Hey, listen,
dude, uh, you know, can I talk to
you for a second? Yeah. Listen, man,
I got am I got, don't know.
I was in, I was in a bad mood
yesterday. I was, you know,
I've been dealing with flood of stuff,
a lot of personal stuff and I,
I just figured, you know, I just,
I just want to say sorry. You know,
I, uh, got a little out of
line yesterday and, um, I,
you know, it was totally my fault and
nothing to do with you, you know, uh,
just, you know, you're doing that faggy
shit that I can't stand, you know,
acting like it was like, wait
a minute. Whoa, Whoa, wait,
what? This is an appalling,
just stop right there to say
you fucking sorry. Don't, don't,
don't bring it around again
and start shitting on me.
So the guy's like, you know,
but fuck it. Everyone's entitled to
their own opinions, speech, et Cetera.
What the fuck ever. I will think it's
cool. You actually write people back now.
He's being nice to me again.
And you're also out there.
I actually like your material.
Thanks again. You know,
and you won't really annoyed me about
his fucking email is that he wrote I'm
back. That was the name of the title.
Like I'm actually like, I fucking
like, he's the only guy
who shits on me in emails.
Like I've been sitting around going,
gee, whatever happened to that guy.
I don't even remember when
this fucking happened. Why not?
Why couldn't you just fucking come back
and start a listening to the podcast?
I don't give a shit what you're doing.
I mean, he told me to go fuck myself.
A called me a pussy,
you know?
Do you know how many of those I get?
The only one I remember was with
somebody gave me shit for supporting.
So take two for taking
the side of a celebrity.
He was like supporting celebrities
and what the fuck did he said, uh,
fuck you.
Bye.
Like he was all done with me
and I just wrote back, alright,
take it easy.
And I just cracked it.
We up. The people are so like, you know,
I'm the supposed to be the guy that
thinks the world is wrapped around him,
not you.
Right?
I mean, these people make
me feel better about myself.
It's fucking guys think like, you know.
Yeah. Listen, I know you're still fucking,
uh, you know, emotionally distraught
about that time. I told you,
go fuck yourself in November of 2006.
I don't remember that.
All right.
Or if you're going to apologize,
just apologize.
Just sales guys kind of being a
cunt. Sorry about that. All right.
And then, and then just
fucking star. Listen again.
I don't eat Annalise and you listen
to your fucking explanations.
Douche bag of the week right
there. God bless you. Welcome
back, sir. Welcome back.
Okay. And you became part of the
podcast. Is that stroke your ego?
Hope you get run over by that fire
truck at the end of the parade. Today.
I never understood the fire truck.
Is that because it's always during
the day and they don't have money for
fireworks or you couldn't
really see the fireworks?
So in the end they got to have those
poor fucking firemen in their raincoats
sweating their asses off.
Huh?
Sweating off that fucking hooker funk
that half of them have on their body,
those heroes.
That's one thing I've learned about
firemen after talking to the cops.
Firemen love hookers.
They love him.
You know?
I'm telling you right now,
half the time you see a fucking
fire truck going down the street.
Half the time they go on and get hookers.
So what they're doing,
I think they have all those extra seats.
Why do you think they have that?
That debt fucking intense.
Look in their face.
The site, the site, they're going
to go get their dick sucked.
You know what was the last
time you even saw a fire?
Every fucking three seconds. You see a
fire truck going down the Damn Street.
There's no fire. They're getting hookers,
but everybody comes down on the cops.
Happy
Memorial Day, everybody. I'm winging
this one. I'm winging this one.
I thought I was going to ask somebody
else talk for the entire fucking time. Um,
you know, in my, my youtube
research, everybody,
when I was sitting there in my lab coat,
my safety goggles doing
youtube research, um, you know,
lately we've been talking about,
you know,
bad covers and people actually started
sending me some covers that were bad,
but they actually thought were good.
Like A,
there's some Ukrainian group
that does like this sort of a,
I don't know what it is, old school,
old school, like European folk,
um, version of highway to hell. So
just search Ukrainian highway to hell,
you know,
the Malcolm and Angus parts or run
an accordion and Phil Rudd's part is
basically an empty suitcase
and somebody hitting a,
an empty water bottle against it and
somehow it's actually pretty bad ass,
pretty bad ass. Those
guys, like they really,
they bring a great energy
to it and I gotta admit,
I kind of enjoyed it because you
would think it would be a train wreck.
So that's your first video to watch
Ukrainian highway to hell. And,
um, anyway, so I was kind
of looking up that uh,
that some of that surf
guitar stuff and uh,
they all use those fender strats and
I got one of those this year and I was
never really a fan. I always
like the Gibson sound with
the Marshall amp cause I,
you know Zeppelin Ac DC like
that's what I came up on.
You know Joe Perry always had
that 59 Les Paul, he used,
you know the deal and um,
I don't know.
I was into the beach boys for like two
seconds and then they just annoyed the
shit out of me. Um, but I don't know,
just trying to learn how to play guitar.
I grabbed, you know, he
listened to a little blues.
It's funny when you go back and listen
to those old blues guys like Lightening
Hopkins is can,
you know,
called lightening cause he was so fast
and compared to how fast guys are today,
he's not that fast.
So you kind of go back to those guys
because you can at least figure out the
rhythm.
I'm just explaining if anybody out there
is trying to learn how to play guitar,
I'm really trying to
learn how to play by ear.
So I'm not like one of those Douche bags
you see on youtube where somebody shows
you how to play the guitar, but in they
still want the tabs, you know what I mean?
Um, so anyways, so then I graduated to
two other Surf Guitar and like I said,
he's a lot of the thought of
the rips are all on one string.
But what I noticed in it
was a,
I came across this group called the
shadows and they got a song called Fbi and
you just have to see the
synchronized dancing,
the choreography that
they're doing. Um, you know,
you guys can keep sending
me the bad covers.
But a whole nother level of funny is
some of the bad choreography because
nowadays when you look at the
choreography that people do, it's like a,
I mean the, the, the dancers
nowadays are so good.
They'll have 20 people on stage and you're
watching them and they're all moving.
They're doing the exact same
move at the exact same time.
And back then in the 60s it was basically,
as long as you were doing
the same movement within
three seconds of the person
to either side of you, it was
considered a, it's considered,
I guess, decent. So check
out a search shadows,
FBI, this is some of the worst
choreography I've seen. And a,
if you want some heavy metal,
this is a whole nother genre and I
haven't even tip even even like tapped the
surface of this.
Look up Brittany Fox and Brittany's
B R I t n y Fox girls' school live.
And just watch the first 10 seconds of
their stupid and back and forth that I
thought was fucking cool as hell. I
literally saw it and was like, oh my God,
this is, this is, uh, I
was like, oh my God. No.
I was like, I literally said, Oh my God,
I know a fucking ditzy girls have ruined
saying, oh my God. But it used to exist,
you know,
like when you saw a Zeppelin fucking
burning back to the goddamn earth with
people on fire jumping out of it.
Oh, that was all the humanity. Um,
and then the last one isn't
even synchronized dancing.
But this is the main reason
why it took me so long.
And I never really got into Dave
Matthews was that stupid dance,
that White Guy, James Brown fucking
dance that Dave Matthews used to do.
Just search Dave Matthews dance and it's,
it's,
you know,
you really just want John Belushi to come
back from the dead and do that animal
house scene where he smashes the
guy's guitar except you really want,
I'm just hit Dave right
over his fucking head.
And the only reason why I ever got
in to listening to Dave Matthews was,
uh, their drummer. And
then I really liked,
there was a saxophone solo that I just
thought was the shit on one of their
earlier, uh, earlier ones. Other
than that, I just, I don't know,
I just haven't been into them. So you
know a few, you know now, right there.
That's a lot of work. That's a lot of
shit to go look up. What? You know what?
Why don't you take the
express checkout line? Okay.
The automated checkout line and just
go to the [inaudible] podcast.com we'll
have all those fucking videos
right up there. You can watch them.
We'll have them in order. The highway
to hell, right? The Dave Matthews,
I mean very little times in life.
Do what would I ever be
on the side of a bully,
but I swear to God if right
in the middle of his dance,
if the stereotypical high school
football player walked up to him with his
jersey,
still on with two of his other meathead
friends and they just stuffed them into
some locker that they brought
on stage and smashed his guitar,
you could hear me laughing from the back
of the fucking stadium that they were
playing. I would completely enjoy it and
I don't know what that says about me.
Oh,
we're 34 minutes in.
I want to give a shout out to
all the joggers on the treadmill.
You only got another word or
another fucking 13 minutes left.
13 minutes left.
All right.
How smelly is the person next to you?
You know,
are you on a treadmill right now?
You know what I love is those,
those fucking people who don't even need
to do cardio and yet they still get on
the machines and they always get on
like that. That old school stair master,
you know those people who just cheat?
They have like a magazine open in
their reading and then they'll look,
they'll like hunched over looking like
a question mark and that just sort of
moving their feet like flip, flip, flip,
flip, flip, flip, flip that. It's like,
what do, what are you doing? Are you
trying to burn fat off of your ankles?
Is that all you're doing? You're not
doing anything. You have full makeup on?
Maybe that's just La.
Do you know one time I was at the gym,
I'm actually going to go outside the
outside the bounds of a, this podcast.
I actually did. I'm going to, I'm
going to sort of name a name here.
I was on a, I was on the fucking
the elliptical, you know,
cause I want to have a hip
replacement when I'm 55.
I wanted to dual the fucking Earl Campbell
special. That's what the fuck I want.
Right? Actually like don't,
I don't universe. I don't.
Okay. I've learned that.
Be careful what you say
your word is your wand. Um,
so I'm at the fucking
gym. All right. And uh,
there's this girl in front of me,
this beautiful girl,
but she's got tattoos all over
a cell phone. I'm just going,
why the fuck did this gorgeous girl get
all those goddamn tattoos right there.
Fucking sweatpants.
They're hanging down.
They can see about a 16th of
an inch of fucking ass crack.
And I'm just going like that girl,
I swear to God,
if you just erased all those tattoos,
okay.
And you put her in a address
that that showed off,
you know, the beauty of a
woman, but it wasn't trashy.
Like this girl is like a
classy gorgeous woman. Right.
But she didn't know.
She said you met sweating,
fucking sweat pants hanging off her and
everything. And like four days later,
she's in the exact same one. I'm fucking
sitting there, I'm doing the elliptical.
There she is against sweat pants hanging
off and just so happened I was done
before and I'm walking by or
cause I gotta go, you know,
get the little fucking bottle of whatever
and spray down the machine I just used
, I looked at her and it was a, Oh,
this is such a Kathy Griffin moment.
I can't add Jesus. I, you
know, I can't tell. I can't
fucking name names that would,
that would ruin the podcast. All right,
I can't do that. I can't do that.
I'll fucking annoying is
that I couldn't do it.
Kathy Griffin has already ruined
the reputation of redheads.
No one's ever going to trust
us with this secret again.
She fucking hangs out with famous people,
right? And they're all going, oh wow.
Isn't this cool?
I'm hanging out with a fucking comedian.
And then she goes on TV
and rats out everything.
Then she picked her nose
and I was like, ah man, God,
Michael Landon just picked his
fucking nose. I know he's dead.
What the fuck? Right. So what am I going
to do? I'm going to do that on my podcast.
I can't do it. All right. I gave
you enough of a description.
There's a beautiful girl with way
too many tattoos. Figure it out,
you know.
Do you know any movie stars who are
beautiful with way too many tattoos?
You don't. All right, so now
out we're out of the movies.
It wasn't a musician to TV star.
Beautiful.
Too many tattoos. There
you go. You figure out
what, are you laughing at me or am I
totally given it away? Now I'm not,
I don't name names.
She just said you're ridiculous.
The amateur thrill I get because I have
no idea if I'm making people laugh.
If you actually left knee,
I know that I'm not wasting my time here.
Yeah, let's see that. I just
got an AH, um, all right.
What am I reading here? Uh, all right.
He did anybody notice last
week when you watch that,
that Sabbath fan going crazy?
How much he sounded like he
could do a dead on Sam Kinison.
I really thought that
that guy was awesome.
Somebody actually sent me in a fucking
hilarious email going like, come on bill,
you think that that because I said that
that guy is actually probably a parent
cause he's at that age.
And he was like, dude,
do you really think anybody's fucking
that guy? I mean look at him. And uh,
I would say this, if there was an even
amount of men and women on this planet,
I would say that he would be in trouble.
All right?
There would be a pussy shortage in his
life that would rival what the fuck we
went through in the early seventies with
the gas, with the, with the gas crunch.
All right. There was a long
fucking way to go. Um, but no,
fortunately there's three
women to every one guy.
So as a man,
if you're dating a loser chick or
someone who's just a total content,
you really have no excuse. But women, they
actually, they have an excuse, you know,
when they say a good man is hard
to find out that they're right.
I would think a man would be hard to find
if there's fucking, you know, you know,
three who has every fucking a hang
down there paying down over there,
you know? All right, let's read this
fucking question here on, you know what?
I don't want to do that. I don't want
to do, I don't want to do that just yet.
Beautiful woman,
not a movie star with a lot of tet,
not a musician. She also does not own
an ice cream store. Okay. That's it.
I'm done with it. I'm done
with the hints. Um, anyways,
and I'm not going to confirm or deny him
either, but I do know the answer, Huh?
He like,
I just went political.
It was one of the greatest quotes ever
heard some lawyer for some fucking guy or
worked in Congress or whatever the fuck
it was. Came walking out and they go,
they go, is it true that blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And this guy just looked at the camera.
He goes,
I can neither confirm nor denied it.
I can either. I fucked it up. He goes,
I can neither confirm nor deny that,
but I do know the answer.
And he walked away. All right.
Put that one in your back pocket.
Next time you're in a fucking jam.
When the cops are asking you a question
when your girlfriend or lay your, oh,
you're cheating on me. You
know, give her Bruce Willis.
Look from die hard. Just look over
your shoulder and then just do that.
Alec Baldwin sort of whisper.
I can neither confirm nor deny that,
but I do know the answer. And then just
sort of look off right over a shoulder,
staring at something and don't break a
gaze and just walk right by the side of
her face. And I'll tell you, yeah, you
completely mind fucked you. You know,
you mind fucked her.
Okay.
And then run down to the corner and try
when the fucking fire trucks come down
the street, grab the side and jump on. Go
down the street. Get yourself a blow job.
Celebrate Memorial Day weekend.
All right,
let's get into the
questions for this week. Um,
I want to remind me to talk
about the 1958 Oldsmobile 88.
That's my new fucking car, you know, fuck
it. You know what? I'm gonna, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna put some pictures up there
and some of my favorite old cars and uh,
the Malibu,
the fucking Chevy impalas,
those early 60 Chevy impalas,
the Lincoln continental error,
JFK getting his brains blown out.
That fucking Eric car. The uh,
I have never been a big Oldsmobile guy.
Even like the muscle cars.
For me it was either the Mustang and
there was certain years of the, uh,
certain years of the um,
the Camaro that I really liked.
Like as much as I liked
the late sixties one,
I think that 19 seventy's Camaro where
they get like death fucking sharp nose on
it is the meanest looking God damn car.
And it's got the corvette
round brake lights, the cars,
the shit and always seem like whenever,
I don't know,
cause it was a little bigger.
It always just seemed like the gear heads
always figure out how to put like some
fucking 700 cubic fucking whatever
the fuck. I don't know about engines.
They put a Goddamn jet engine in the
thing. Oh, and here's another thing too.
Jay Leno,
I'm fucking obsessed with
his car collection and I'm
always going on his website.
Jay Leno's garage or whatever.
We'll have the link on the
[inaudible] podcast.com. Um,
he has a fucking look up Jay Leno.
Here's another youtube video.
Look up Jay Leno tank car,
this fucking maniac.
But uh, uh, an engine,
he took it out of a tank,
never get dentally Chrysler
Dodge made it cause it's a Hemi,
but it's like a fucking 58 cylinder and
he made a hot rod out of it and open
wheel hot rod. The fucking car is like,
I swear to God, it's like 25 feet long.
It's longer than the 58 continental
right near one of the longest production
cars of all time. I was actually
talking to my dad about all cars.
He knows all about old cars.
You know,
he used to do that when we were kids all
the time. Be driving down the street.
We see a car [inaudible] car.
I'd be like,
dad is a 1955 Buick special
at a three 50 God, that was a beautiful
car. That's all we always ended with guy.
That was a beautiful car actually,
when one time watching one of those Dudley
movies where he plays a drunk and you
know,
he drives his Rolls Royce and he comes
screeching in hammered and he rear ends
another car.
And my dad loves cars so much.
He's literally watching it and as,
as the dude is coming in in that
screeching in the car and it's so clear,
he's going to hit a fire hydrant or
whatever with that, that $5,000 grill,
remember that 16 candles? You got five
grand and I've got five grand, right?
He comes flying.
My Dad is literally going,
making that noise, you know, liquid.
Something precious is going to break
and it fuck he rear ends the car.
Then my dad's like, well,
why did they have to do that?
I'm just sitting there laughing.
Go ahead dad.
It's probably a fake Royal Rolls Royce,
you know? And he goes, yes, but I know,
but whatever the fuck that means.
My Dad's hilarious and he and I and I,
whatever is in his DNA about
loving cars from the 50s,
forties and, and uh, the 60s I got that.
I don't know what happened. I tapped
into that shit. But like I said,
I'd never been an Oldsmobile guy,
but there is a fucking 1958 Oldsmobile
88 that this guy really did.
That is um,
it's gold and uh,
just if those front four headlights, it's
amazing because the Chevy's went from,
from two headlights to, for between
57 and 58. And I always hated that.
I hated how the Bel Air looked cause it
just ended up looking like a checker cab.
I like the 55 to 57 Bel air when
it had the single head light.
We want to just the classic, you know,
from Memorial Day American car designs,
how the fuck we went to that. And
I was actually thinking, you know,
I have a kid here,
you know,
am I really going to drive
down the street going,
that's a fucking 1987 Chevy Lumina.
God, that was a beautiful car. I'm not
even gonna know what the fuck it was.
Ford Astro. I'm not going to know
what it was. They all look the same,
but back then they had like,
it was a man like,
you know what I liked
about the cars back then,
and I might be wrong here because this
is a, you know, like I said, I'm not,
I'm not a fucking mechanic
obviously and shit,
but like back then the way they had
things broken down was, you know,
nowadays like,
um,
I like how can I put
this like it like Toyota,
we'll make everything from
uh, from a, uh, like a Prius,
low end car.
Like what?
I drive all the way up to a high
end car that'll still say Toyota.
I know they have Lexus and all that, but
Toyota we'll make like a, like a 50,000,
$60,000 car and they'll make like
an 18,000, $20,000 current and all.
It's all under the brand name.
Toyota,
we're back in the day as far as
my understanding of it was Canada.
They went Cadillac, Buick,
Oldsmobile, Plymouth,
Chevrolet,
and Chevy's were like bottom and cars,
you know, and then if you drove up, it's,
it was like the status was like, what? Uh,
what make you a drive?
And I believe,
at least that's the way I kind of
understand if you drove a Chevy,
you kind of a young guy, you know, um,
making your way up the ladder and you go
back to your high school reunion and be
like, what? What's he
driving? Striving a Plymouth,
a fucking shitty was driving a
Chevy in high school. The fuck,
how old is he? You know, but if
you, if you got up to, you know,
Buick and Oldsmobile, you're doing are
right, but if you're driving a Cadillac,
you will fucking run and shit.
And I think that work the same way with
like Chrysler where when Chrysler, the
Sodo Plymouth and then dodge, I don't
know, I just remember when I was in,
when I was sitting and was in a bar in
Colorado and they had this old school
poster that said, buy your
wife a Chevy, which is funny.
It's like, Hey, buy one of those low
end cars that'll shut her the fuck up.
Probably doesn't even mean that.
It's just how my chauvinist
stick mine took dead. Anyways,
let's, let's, uh, well,
well, we'll have a picture
of like, I'll say like, uh,
like three or four of my most favorite
American cars in celebration of a
memorial day weekend and all the troops,
you know, uh, you know what I mean?
I can barely handle being in Arizona.
I don't know how the fuck I
would ever survive. You know,
if I was ever going to go to war,
I should have gone to war back in
the day when we were, uh, well,
I guess we used to fight in the tropics.
Jesus Christ. That would have been,
you know, I probably could do they
let red heads into the fucking army.
You probably, that's is it,
can I get a deferment for having no
pigment? I've never seen an albino marine,
you know what I mean? Can I get,
that's like having flat feet.
I've got a bad back. I'm a red head.
What? W what are you going to stick me?
All right. You want to fucking have
hand to hand combat and Greenland?
I'm there baby. I'm fucking right
there. I'll have a knife from my teeth.
I'll take out a polar bear.
I swear to God I won't cower.
And my little fucking Igloo crying is
someone else's going private Burke.
Get your shit together.
I don't want to go out there.
It's scary
me.
I am killing with you this week.
I'm fucking funny today. See how
women, they always got to clarify it.
Why can't you just say your fucking
funny? I'm funny today. You know what?
That's what God made you.
So beautiful.
You'd come in here with your
hair looking all glamorous.
I was really mad at you twice.
I saw you come walking in here like
some old school movie star. See that?
See how I do that?
I insult him and then I quickly
compliment him and then I get the yard.
What do you have in your hand?
I am.
That's why you like me and women
like the assholes they do, right?
Cause you know we know how to fuck.
Wow.
Anyways. Oh, whatever. I'm shit talking.
It's a holiday. Somebody rubbing my balls.
Drinking a beer in a minute cause I'm an
American. You think I'm going to read,
I'm not that extra day.
Going to get dumber.
That's what I'm doing and be puking
in a fucking BFI. Been behind Dennis.
All right, here we go. Um, here's
a question for a week, a bill.
Let me start by saying this.
This question stems from event
spanning over the last six years or so.
About six years ago at the age of 20,
I was about a year and a half into what
at the time seem to be a really great
relationship.
Coincidentally,
my job and money situation
was also doing really well.
Um, so I decided instead of
throwing my money away on rent,
I buy a house. There you go. This guy's
making the moves. He's doing well in life.
He's buying a house. Everything's good.
So far, being that I always plan ahead.
I purchased a rather nice
house for a first home,
even though I thought, uh, he said,
even thought I knew it, even though I
knew it was a little too much money. Um,
now I didn't decide I didn't buy
this to start a family or for her.
I just wanted a fucking house.
I'm in the year or so after the
relationship really went downhill,
mainly because I was working more in
spending less time and money on her.
Um, okay. Uh, long story short,
we split about two years later.
Since then, I've had many encounters
with girls. Okay. So let me,
let me fix this with my awful
reading. All right. Basically,
this guy's dating a girl.
He's making good money.
He doesn't want to throw his money
down the toilet, pay in rent.
So he goes and he buys in house and then
now he's got a nut to fucking crack.
Every month he works a little bit more.
He's not spending time with his woman
and it goes downhill. Plus he's younger.
That's pretty normal,
except the fact that he owns a house.
So now he's in this situation,
he's single.
He has this really nice house and this is
what's been happening since. All right.
Since then,
I've had many encounters with girls.
The one thing they have all had in common
is their hatred and animosity towards
my ex-girlfriend and my house.
I've even heard them say things about
sleeping in a bed I bought with her or how
they don't like it that I did all
this with uh, with the other girl.
I'd been dating a girl for about two
years now and she's the same way. Uh,
she even has problems with my dogs
because she says they were her dogs,
meaning the ex. My question is this,
why is it never good enough? Well,
if you're a fan of this podcast,
you've already asked that question,
but I think it's timeless. So I'm going
to, that's why I'm reading this again.
Am I supposed to start my life over
every time I want to begin a new
relationship or is it that girls are
really always want to have what they can.
They cannot have half the country nowadays
are just waiting for some guy to put
them up in a house and
take care of everything.
But when you give them the chance,
the they bitch because they didn't
get to pick the fucking drapes.
Ah, this guy's making some good points
near, I'm going to need your help pair.
He said, uh, I don't, uh, I don't get it.
I've done really well for myself
and I've done it on my own.
None of that had anything to do
with who I was dating at the time.
And I hate the feeling bad
because I'm trying to make,
because I'm trying to better
myself. What's your take? All right,
Nia, what, what did you say on this? You
actually summed it up really well here.
What do you, what do you think about this
guy? Just to, just to reiterate, you know,
the deal. What, what, what
is, uh, what is his problem?
I think the problem is the kind of people
that he dates cause I don't think that
there mature enough. So like let go
of the past, you know what I mean?
It's like, of course he's dated other
women, of course. You know what I mean?
It's not, yeah, but let me ask you this.
If, if when I met you already had a house,
right.
And uh, it was, you know, it had a
little bit of the female touch to it,
you know what I mean?
Yeah. You know what I mean?
It's not like you walked in and there was
just a coffee table and like fucking a
playstation, you know, popcorn in
the cushions or whatever. Right.
I'm not saying this house looks like that,
but you know.
Right. Yeah. No. If it looked like,
and I still had the bed that I
used to bang the other one me,
then I'll say at least she can do it.
Dude, you can least switch out the bed.
You know what I mean? Bed though.
I thought, I think that's a little,
I think that's a little much, honestly.
What a little much to still have it. Yeah.
He's going to buy it.
Do you? How much bets?
Cause you don't have him buy a whole new
bed just cause he's slept with somebody
else on it. Ladies. Can you see why
this is my girl? You're the shit.
Yeah,
because I mean how many,
when you're dating somebody and you
have sex with them in their house,
chances are they've had sex with somebody
else in their bed before you anyway.
So now all of a sudden it's
like a big deal because no,
he needs to date some more mature girls,
but he's been dating someone for two
years. I don't know what he's been doing.
I thought you said he, I just
focus on saying the words, right?
Yeah. He says, you know what?
You know what this, this
house could be like the lock,
the lock, the door test in them in a
Bronx tale. Oh yeah, that's true. Yeah.
Like if they can't deal with it and they
start giving me shit and you give him
the heave Ho. Exactly. I think they
should get the heave Ho this is my house.
This is where I fuck you want in the,
not quite so asshole. But if
anything he could, you know,
get some new sheets or something,
you know, obviously. Yeah,
the bed bath and beyond.
I was thinking about some new sheets.
You want to help me pick out? Some
girl would love that. Love it. Yeah.
There you go. Yeah, there you go. Yeah,
and what point in the relationship
should he do that? You know,
cause we don't like being tied down.
I want to send the wrong message.
I don't want to say that I love you,
but I want you to still bang me.
Like at what point?
I think when it's like official date,
like a monogamous type thing is when
you can say, hey, let's you know.
Okay. All right. That's really, you
answered the question, don't oversell it.
You answered it. It gets really
annoying that these girls would be like,
oh my God,
I can't
believe you that you know this is already
decorated and these are her dogs and
this is her house. And I can tell that
she said that there. That's stupid.
That's really how la girls say.
Favorite after that fabric.
All right. All right. I think that's
going to be the podcast this week.
So I guess so that's your answer
right there when you know,
I'm not going to always
defer those, uh, Tinea,
but I just think sometimes you're really
asking me what women are thinking and I
think I've done enough trashing
of women and uh, shut up.
Um, I've done enough trash,
one of them. And you know,
that's actually a serious question here
because still you don't want to get that
in a situation where,
I mean you have to,
I mean literally sell the house.
What if it's a bad fucking market just to
appease her. That's ridiculous. But, uh,
I, I w I, you know something, yeah,
I would actually say that if they were
actually going to be getting married,
you know,
if they take it to that level and uh,
there'll be a weird thing because when
you do get married and you want to pick
out a house, it's the house that for
both of you that you want to live in.
And you know, this houses out there
that I just don't get like that though.
You know that gingerbread looking
house sits up to fucking street? Yeah.
Like you know,
if I met the girl and my dreams and she
lived in that house and every everyday
driving, ah, I hate this fucking house.
You know all those ones that look like
the castles, that employee. But they're,
they're just a house so it looks stupid.
You know,
Rapunzel let down your hair or
just sort of hop out that window.
No, I, I do. I know, I respect
that, but I'm saying I, this
is what I was saying like,
you know, come on in and live here.
I get that. But then you know,
I'm sure we didn't buy a house
that's big enough to have like a,
like a big family. I don't
know if he does. I don't know.
I'm just trying to kind of balance it out.
Allow, what the fuck am I trying to do?
Nia,
are you going to be designated driver?
Because I'm going to get
hammered today. A drag. Why?
I was designated driver last time.
Last time when last time.
Last time,
like fucking three weeks
ago when we were in Boston.
And you guys all got Hamad is they
say, oh yeah, we're going to somebody.
We don't know these people. We can't
go get hammered. I can. I'm going to,
you know, my mission is I'm going to
make you look good today. I'm going to,
you're going to people gonna feel
bad for you. No, I don't want that.
We'll figure it out. Come on then I
send you those songs that I make up.
You don't want to get drunk.
Yeah. Be Fun. I'll be,
I'll be asleep halfway,
halfway
with my mouth open.
Looking like the ass hole next to you
on a fucking transcontinental flight.
All right. That's it. Happy Memorial
Day to everybody. Sorry. The uh,
nick Swardson thing didn't work out.
I'm going to try to sneak in an
extra podcast this week. Um, I'm,
I'm going to figure this shit out.
Okay? I promised you a movie, goddammit.
I'm going to bring you one and a, that's
it. A Happy Memorial Day to everybody.
Have a nice, safe, happy holiday.
Get to where the fuck you going to be
at and just start boozing. All right.
Okay. Don't be that asshole. I'm fine.
I'm fine. You're not fine. All right.
Two Sec. You, you have grass
stains on your face. Okay.
You're not fine.
Have you been drinking tonight?
I had a couple Saad hanging off
your fucking left here. All right,
everybody, that's it. Have a great
weekend and a happy holiday and
ah, that's it. God bless the troops. Okay.
[inaudible]
no,
it was his ball.
Barron's mood and come
directly home robbery
charge that I draw
large,
large.
Explain it always.
Just
[inaudible].